[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Закарпаття, м. Виноградів
Боржавська вузькоколійка]
Фактично, йшла боротьба між двома містами —
Мукачево і Берегово. Це цікава легенда.
Ужгород свій статус отримав...
[Денис Добра
Голова ГО «Боржавська вузькоколійка»]
у 20-30-их роках минулого сторіччя,
бо до того Ужгород
не був таким впливовим містом.
Дуже цікава склалась ситуація.
Коли з'явилась ідея будівництва
цієї вузькоколійки в долині річки Боржави,
то можете собі уявити, що громада —
торговці з Мукачева — була категорично
проти будівництва цієї залізниці.
Шість років відбувались судові засідання,
щоб не дати можливість будувати цю гілку.
Чому? Фактично...
Берегове отримувало в такому разі
дуже потужний вихід на Верховину.
Не треба було йти півтора дня на ярмарок до Берегового.
Завдяки потягу це скоротилось до 3 годин.
Чесно кажучи, це будівництво дало великий
поштовх всьому регіону боржавської долини.
Тому що залізниця проходить
по берегах річки Боржави, яка сягає 104 км.
І фактично, цей весь регіон отримав
ефективну транспортну інфаструктуру.
Це було в 1908 році.
На відкриття приїхав сам
міністр фінансів Угорщини.
Можемо сказати, що до 1976-1978 року
це була одна з найважливіших артерій
на Закарпатті. Чому?
Автобусне сполучення ще не було так розвинуте.
Наведу вам приклад.
Гірські регіони Боржави —
це українське населення.
Угорщина починається
за Нижніми Реметами і Виноградовим.
І сталось так, що...
Для багатьох верховинців
Берегово стало важливим центром.
Чому? Бо завдяки залізниці шукали
сучасну роботу, на борових, у розвідці і тд.
Працювали і здобували освіту в Береговому.
Берегове ставало таким
дуже потужним центром.
Сьогодні в Україні збереглося
тільки три такі залізниці.
Антонівка-Зарічне — це Полісся.
Закарпаття — це боржавська вузькоколійка.
На Одещині — Гайворон, Рудниця.
Для порівняння: якщо в 45-мільйонній країні
є три осередки такого технічного туризму,
історичної спадщини,
то сусідня Угорщина, яка налічує 8 мільйонів,
має 25 вузькоколійок. Я не говорю за широку.
І якщо проаналізувати цю пропорцію,
це покаже, де ми є.
Це не про пісні співати в шароварах
і показувати, які в нас вишиванки красиві.
А з погляду, де є суспільство,
яке віддає шану техніці.
А хто не шанує техніку —
буде копать мотикою.
На коліях позначено угорського виробника — 1890 рік.
Дивіться, 1908 рік — угорсько-бельгійське підприємство.
І ця стрілка з цього часу тут працює.
Можете уявити 1908 рік,
а сьогодні маємо вже 2016.
Хочемо, щоб ці вагони не різали.
Оці вагони хочуть на металобрухт відправити.
Це в тоді, коли поляки приходять сюди, стають на коліна і плачуть: дайте нам один вагон.
Продайте нам. Ми вам можемо
один [вагон ]відремонтувати.
Дайте нам один задарма —
ми вам один відремонтуємо.
Сьогодні Укрзалізниця не оперує термінами економії, ефективності і тд.
Тому що це локомотив 1972 року,
можете собі уявити.
Вагони також модерні — 1979-1980 року.
І коли ми хвалимось,
що в нас супутники літають у космос і так далі,
як французи кажуть sophistiqué [вишукане].
У нас тут просте обладнання, але на сьогодні
жодної інвестиції в ці речі немає.
Жодної, жодної, нуль...
Міст Боржавський.
Він збудований за технологією
гарячого клептання деталей, як і Ейфелева вежа.
Самі розумієте: це не є класична туристична атракція,
де люди можуть собі сісти і відпочити.
Це трохи екстрим.
Інколи буває, що туристичні фірми просять:
«Привезімо до вас на залізницю людей».
І ти потім маєш проблеми на свою голову...
Бо люди хочуть комфортних умов,
але такого тут нема.
Бо це така атракція, яка може дати Закарпаттю
та Шаланкам дуже багато з погляду економіки.
На виставці 1886 року в Парижі
була презентація технології вузькоколійки.
Як інфраструктуру її було реалізовано
через 20 років після тієї презентації.
Скажіть мені, які сьогодні винаходи,
що ви бачили у світі, були реалізовані десь у нас,
тут, на місці, окрім того, що ми маємо?
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Монтаж
Антон Шинкаренко]
[Музика
Антон Подольникй, Fudo Kazuki]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]